bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video su gta 5 siamo trovati con
lo step oggi faremo una rampa che però
io sono pigro non l'ho cercata la scelta
lui e chi parte quella morte che
l'incubo più facile di tutti adesso ci
pensi quale l'altra volta in esso
collegata cos'è un rom e karam pd e ci
aspetta che ciò c'è veramente aspetta
eccolo
sono partito velocissimo ma è una gara
utili sono buttare ne so no no mi sono
cagato nelle mutande 6 e molto sentite
ma è molto diverso da quello che mi
aspettavo è molto diversa anche secondo
me problema è che hai fatto tu già
loclai dando cosa vuol dire non capisco
è una mostra di gta che ti permette di
volare con la moto l'esperimento l'aereo
perfetto anche anche un aereo perché già
arrivato e lettere stessi libri valerio
a ecco perché è un dato velocissima
donna che aereo gustato dove deve
entrare dove le entrare non presentato
ma diventerà qua dentro dove deve
entrare mamma verde a gattorna fa tutti
i sensi
ma qualcuno gliel'ha spiegato che
soggette incontrollabile accoglierò
ultimamente lo utilizzano costantemente
in queste rampe è un inferno è il non
fare niente
forse l'ho presa non l'ho presa voglio
prenderla non riesco neanche ad arrivare
al 3 va a prendere il primo caso sono
forse ero figlio ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta ho messo due ore ma ce
l'ho fatta a posto ma è un casino
beh dai per adesso niente male niente
male niente male stefy niente male
niente male niente male niente male
niente male
bravissimo guarda che provo che sono ma
ce l'ho fatta
come ho fatto a faccia non si non è
possibile che ci sia veramente
non male non male mammamia sotto fatto
approvata eccola posti dal centro
ecco la voce e vabbè ho capito ma cosa
c'entra vo io eccola volti a mi ha
frenato ok va bene è però senza circus è
su facebook funziona da dio
abbiamo madonna mi sei passato mi hai
fatto la basetta mi sono riesplose no
riesplode no no no andando per strada
salve tutto a posto ragazzi un big mac è
un cheeseburger grazie a dio o dio o dio
sto andando io e ottenuto le paste
installazione non ci questa io non gira
è quello il suo problema ce l'ho fatta
bravo ce l'ho fatta non so come ma è
stato un disastro arrivo grazie posso
andare io grazie anche se la vedo dura
guardare lei che voglio aia scherzavo
allora faccio un po come vuole non lo so
e va bene allora giocato salve salve
buongiorno buongiorno prego perché di
nominare la vita di genova che non la
sto controllando non ecco infatti ciao
sono con la tua vecchia di prima
guarda che bello che sono io speriamo ma
cos'è aia stata l'auto ma cos'è veit
segue l'intero pianeta centro reti
beccate l'attuale visivi si toglie la
sola troppo verazzo e per il mio
camioncino ok volta
eccoci da piccole serio dritto è di 6
anch'io ma poi un altro si diventa
diventa 3 corsia quando inizia a
capottarsi l'hanno fatto apposta si ebbe
insistito perché poi ti e cappotti e non
cadi e non grazie a parma 90 delle volte
non tipo questa mia non si sa mai
no no ce l'ho fatta camioncino
totalmente dall'altra parte come in
forti ma cos'è questo di nuovo il camion
è un pullman atti donavano io no non
c'era il voli con vision vanno date
cifre godiamoci insieme ti prego i
driver affianca un altro amatissimo dai
eccoci stabili o ancora devi toccare
redatto rialzista madonna
no non vedo l'ora di provare il tuo
guarda già finita camioncino non so come
hai fatto ingestibile ed ha infatti di
strattonare a caso finché nella vita non
ti ha detto non ci arrivo di ogni assi
ci sono arrivato è diventato un
truffatore
eccolo eccolo lo stack
eccolo addio a me ne vado luci che si è
caduto no no no no no
[Risate]
cosa è successo
obiettivo rimanere al centro ma non
rimane lui si dice ora sono nato a casa
un altro nato attenzione sta arrivando
aiuto e noi che si non tanta non ti devi
ha detto no esci dal cambio un imbarazzo
non male tieni tieni tieni tieni tieniti
micheli è un buona volta non è male
stavolta non è male stavolta non è male
ok non male è finita anche nei due ore
c'è una macchina incredibile aiuto è una
rosa o quella che sembra un fulmine ma
quella mi sa che salta se primi l3
assisi si sicuro però non usando
l'acceleratore sembra funzionare vediamo
ok perché ha un controllo aereo
no ci per mi sono salvato sventando alla
fine mi sono salvato si è perché questa
qua un controlla ero niente male quindi
non cliccare nulla e raddrizzati quanto
rimbalza e mettere però power metal un
bene io perfetto per il mio aereo quindi
no dai
togliti mi dissocio vediamo guarda caso
da solo non c'è bisogno 26 no non è vero
non è vero non sono caduto devi
toglierti da lì
mamma mia il carnet karma fai ancora in
tempo secondo me
addio santo mount azzardare che spero fa
schifo l'ho pure fatta in crisi l'ha
creato ma se devi esiste nella vita
reale e sto schifo
può essere ma 12 solo propulsore vieni
lavoro è peggiore della vita e guidare
questa era allora il mondo praticamente
sì quando pensi avere un brutto lavoro
né di pensare di poter far questo è il
seguente fumi da tutto il tempo
no aspetta al traguardo no non l'avevo
visto che dal traguardo soldi ci sono
andato a prescindere le prove come sono
appunto alla fine dedicare perché la
bambina che anche la fa filiera grazie e
complimenti dai un amico proprio
guardando ti sto guardando i tre un
amico trova un tesoro e non hai trovato
un tesoro sicuramente però mai provato
infatti una volta voglio vedere per
santa chiara esatto no è che c'è il
freno ti frega poteva andare benissimo
non lo sapremo mai ma dei ragazzi non
avevo visto traguardo prestata la
bellissima gara per avere sia piaciuto
il cagliari che il canale lista ventola
di descrizione potevi se volete altro
campo di gta magari consigliate c'era
anche a noi come sempre ragazzi ci
vediamo al prossimo video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]